foreign
just 10 minutes away from the Jersey
Shore
a small suburban town of Oakhurst home
to the family run Mike and Nellis opened
in 1996 the restaurant was the lifelong
dream of two men Nellie Farber and his
son Mike I wanted to name it Nelly
Mike's but he said no it's Mike and
Nellie's you're the man because he's
that kind of guy everybody loved my
father everybody would come in to talk
to Nelly he knew everybody's name made
everybody feel special he was the front
of the house my dad puts the back that
was the front we're a very good team we
brought in the people and I kept them
here everything was going great until
now we passed away
foreign
[Music]
died we didn't really know what to do
anymore I felt weird to be here like
it's not really my Canales without Nelly
now it's just kind of Mike and nothing
all right let me go write a check when
he left this Earth I had to take over
doing everything that he did Ice Cream
delivered plus what I do and it just
become overwhelmed slow the [ __ ] down
okay I know it's pretty bad since my
Grandpa died the restaurant's been
neglected hi is there anything that I
can help you with yeah
oh okay
restaurant is grimy the carpet is a mess
it's nasty crusty moldy it's tragic to
look around I think they need to redo
the exploration
people they don't come here for
atmosphere they come here for food and
the food here I believe is great
there's something wrong with it like
chemicals how's everything with your
dinner anything you want to share with
me
it makes food it's really not up to
standard Mike do me a favor give
question 22 please I got it when I first
started Mike would never just dump the
food out into the plate now it's like it
doesn't matter but yet at the same time
he thinks that this food is great they
don't like it
okay it just says it has no taste oh
really yeah I've only been making French
taste for 35 years I believe this [ __ ]
the biggest problem that Mike and
Nellie's isn't the decor honestly the
big problem is Mike if I didn't go out
all right
he feels that he comes in he has to take
care of everything did I call for veal
Capri I got it give it to me right this
is my job he doesn't let other people
take moral responsibility it's just
becoming too much for him I want to get
my drink
since Uncle Nelson's passing Mike does
drink quite a bit I put a beer in the
freezer a couple beers and there isn't
hot there are some nights where he's
just completely hammered where's the two
flounders I don't know where anything is
today it starts to affect the food and
he starts to mess things on the tickets
I don't even know how many delays I got
but you know what I'm doing man my dad
is my hero and it's very difficult to
know that my hero is struggling and like
gasping for air you know
I really wish I was able to ignore the
fact that this is my dad's life I really
really hope that Chef Ramsay can help
[Music]
foreign
Chef Ramsay arrives at Mike and Nellie's
there's a young woman anxious to fill
him in on the issues of the restaurant
Mike's oldest daughter Samantha thanks
for helping us nothing right yeah good
to see you thanks for picking me up I'm
excited for you to be here well I'm
excited to be here first time for me
um have you been I'm all right yeah yeah
I just we really need help right now
yeah yeah a lot of problems with the
restaurant what's the one thing that you
think is wrong with it ever since my
Grandpa died if my dad he hasn't been
able to move forward okay
how close are they they worked together
for 18 years my grandpa he was in front
of the house he would host and people
would come to my Canales only to see him
he was a great guy he was very funny and
how's that changed over the last couple
of years he's very overwhelmed and
stressed but he likes to do everything
by himself we just can't delegate right
definitely a control freak he's the boss
you know everywhere in his life he's the
boss so it'll be very interesting when
you have stuff to say to him well
I hope Chef Ramsay can get through to my
dad he needs the help he needs the
change it's crucial from the restaurant
to survive and be successful for my
family I mean that's my whole life
foreign
thank you amazing amazing um
what's that smell is this me I don't
know guys I take a big deep breath if I
should come back
okay wait ready
[Music]
all right
I'll go get him
what's that smell like can you smell
something no how are you good to see you
same here someone say hello and you are
Louis Lewis the manager are you the
manager yes yeah good to see you same
here Dad yes ma'am Chef Ramsey would
like to meet you ready me why me I don't
know
doesn't make any sense why would you
want to meet you
follow me I am quite nervous about Chef
Ramsay's visit and how my dad's
self-esteem will take it because he has
a hard time taking criticism this is my
father Mike Mike I'm Mike pleasure but
the fact is we need the help and if
somebody's willing to give it to us we
need to take it
I really hope that he can help that
15 years 15 years yeah when was the last
time you changed something in the diner
uh never wow everything's pretty much as
I bought it yeah 15 years ago
and how would you rate your food one to
ten I would rate my food in the upper
90s wow great I love that I can't wait
to taste it the food is not the problem
here it's either the atmosphere the
Ambiance or the service
here's your regular menu and here's your
specials menu sir someone PP on my menu
I don't know that's not a urine
statement I don't think so I'm pretty
sure it's probably coffee okay great
thank you if you need anything I'm at
the front
hello hello hello hello
how are you and I'll be your server
tonight good to see you
smell yes obviously it's like that we've
buried like bodies underneath the kelp
yes it's most definitely the carpet it
stinks the restaurant is filthy
disgusting it's full of mold it's worse
over there
seriously you're in the good part
thank you very much
um steak and seafood and we have Italian
food do you need what is it fine dining
restaurant or Italian what are we I
don't know
there is no identity
okay I'll start with Greenery shrimp
sauce and let's go for chicken Murphy
and then the special menu the steak
Nelly yeah how would you like that
cooked midrand okay please thank you
very much you're very welcome I want to
see what that nine out of ten is hitting
it's only about there yeah I'm moving
Chef Ramsay's order here we go Chef
Ramsey will like the food here anything
that I make him he's gonna like
guaranteed
look at this place
Louis Chef welcome to that membership
over there on the wall
I don't know
it's bugging me how are you nice to see
it's driving me crazy I'm sorry oh it
comes on when it goes up anyway
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you you're welcome
green sauce
oh dear
wow it was gross he has plans just the
sauces watery and shrimps up like rubber
just horrible
nowhere near a nine all right would you
like me to remove that from you yes
please the sad part is this isn't even
the worst of it this is Bland watery the
shrimp tastes like rubber I don't know
what he's talking about I am a
perfectionist I will never put out food
unless it's right is this the Murphy
yeah
Ken Murphy chicken Murphy
wow I was afraid to serve him the
chicken Murphy it doesn't look very nice
is it it's embarrassing it looks like a
stew gone bad that looks horrible okay
where's the manager Louis
is that the normal style of presentation
of chicken Murphy Sam Lexi
girls I'm visually impact and does that
look appetizing to you could definitely
use an appearance update a little mush
mush
after Nelly died the food's been kind of
going downhill it's kind of at the point
where it's necessary for someone to say
something
that's gross it's overcooked just wet
soggy and just tasteless I call it a hot
mess
I call it a hot joke I'm done thanks
then yes thank you you're welcome sir I
can't afford to be up all night with the
[ __ ]
oh
excuse me thank God you're gonna have a
chicken Murphy bloody hell
Mike it's just a hot mess so hey tough
son of a [ __ ] Chef Ramsay is a ball
buster but if you have a impossible math
problem if Einstein was still alive you
talk to him so we have a restaurant
problem we talk to the master
things
for the better you can tell them Chef
Ramsay being so critical of the food it
kind of hurt my dad a little bit but my
dad needs help and if this is what it
takes then this is what it takes
for the finale it's going to be the
steak Nelly
I don't need to give him any more things
to hate
grew up cooking steaks and a master of
the grill I'm telling you I'm good at
this one I'm very good at this wow this
is the steak Nelly steak Nelly
the staple charcoal oh Chef that's a
piece of the stick wow
[Music]
oh god wow that just takes a burnt
charcoal I feel like I've got a barbecue
in my mouth I'm gonna taste that
how does that taste for you would you
give that a nine no no like you said it
is charcoal
foreign
like you said there's a little bit of uh
charcoal there ain't no way in hell I
overcooked that steak that's something
that I make that everybody loves and I
never have a complaint
aren't you gonna go out there or what I
don't know shouldn't you go out there
you are the owners they're supposed to
check on things
I hope my dad will be willing to listen
to Chef Ramsay and take the criticism
and acknowledge that everything isn't
perfect sit down instead of just being
mad
uh Mike I'm uh you know I'm embarrassed
so we've got some [ __ ] big issues
here I thought the food was dated I
don't know how you control the menu
outside and then some of the things were
in editable good food there was watery
plant and Soggy I know come on the whole
thing just looked an absolute [ __ ]
mess I mean that last day right I mean
how did you put a dish like that
together well the steak itself is a
fried steak so uh mine was overcooked so
I had no Prime
you raise the food 9 out of ten I
wouldn't pass it above two that's not
good enough to come out for nowhere near
it
I mean I'm just going to tell you man a
man it's not true
either you're in denial or you don't
care
Chef Ramsey said by food was outdated
and yeah I respect him but I believe
he's wrong in this situation I know what
my cousins like and I know what I like
that's what I like that
[Music]
after a lunch that left a lot to be
desired Chef Ramsay is back at Mike and
Nellie's for dinner hi there can I help
you and he isn't alone word of his
arrival is spread and the restaurant is
booked solid for the evening pre-rush
beer
portobello mushroom with jumbo alone
so enjoyed artichoke Alfredo shrimp farm
just tell me quickly how it works line
wise here's what happens they do all the
cooking and then he'll put the food out
I don't trust myself to get the job done
like I can do it as long as I'm making
it I know it's 100 yeah I got Snapper
and pepper I got Penny vodka I got
chicken farm all right despite the fact
that most of the cooking has been done
by one person shrimp farm eggplant parm
give me 14. all right Mike manages to
push out food rapidly
our friend Lobster rap all right take
this and go but his quick cooking wow
look at this first unfortunately comes
at a cost not good not good at all
there's nothing wrong with your pets
G hey guys if I call Amari just let you
know it was mushy it wasn't good they
enjoy it just give you a heads up on
that nice talking
actually something wrong with that
nothing at all
it's embarrassing there's a man in there
that is killing himself
and he's going down in flames
there's no stand-up set everything's
just so chaotic times have been thrown
Stakes are on fire and these sort of
totally oblivious to the kind of crap
that's leaving his kitchen it's actually
quite sad
what's wrong with that I said it's
overcooked all right does that clam
roller TV she says it's the worst that
clinch you ever had it's not even rolled
Mike let's say it was burnt
it's hard to bring food back to Mike
because Mike thinks the food is
excellent I know he's been cooking for
30 years but the food is really not up
to par
onions are a little charcoal are they a
little too well done for you let me take
them away and bring some fresh ones for
you all right sir thank you so much
since Nellie's past the kitchen is a
disaster
the food is not what it used to be it's
extremely frustrating Mike can I get
more of our onions but not too burnt
please dried onions be charred onions
mark this child is charcoal
you're absolutely correct that's
charcoal
I need a charred onion right now on the
outside Mike is really not showing any
kind of emotions but if you look into
his eyes you see this heartbreak this
beating that he's taking internally it's
depressing
is everything going back there disaster
does your dad work like that every night
yeah at least destroying himself I mean
he's just absolutely known himself he
doesn't delegate as well as he shows
like he's reading the ticket then he's
getting it ready and then he's cooking
it and then he's reading another order
and it's hard to watch yeah how are you
supposed to run an entire restaurant
cook everybody's meal by yourself like
you can't do that hot stuff coming
through he doesn't really trust anybody
else in the kitchen to help him and it's
a problem Mike yes I need to worry about
that uh Reef fire on Penny vodka hold on
a minute girlfriend
I'm going as fast as I can baby
all right I want this night to be over
here's a penne vodka Take It Go
all the tickets are out there's nothing
left all right guys Spirits for
everybody go grab them man one for me
too right
[Music]
I'm not the word
watching both you behind the line in
that kind of commotion though it's like
soldiers on the front line
in your mind you've got it now that if
you get through this battle tonight's a
success you just want to get that food
out
do you enjoy cooking like that I don't
know if I enjoy it that's just like what
I do but I mean I bust my ass I cook
until we're done cooking working hard is
one thing working fast and throwing food
out with no care is another
Noah's monitoring standards and no one
seems to care
you are running yourself into the ground
Dan can I have a word with yeah yes sir
will you shut the door please certainly
[Music]
listen seriously have you been drinking
I'm having a vodka cranberry juice
I saw you drinking something two beers
two bits two beers that is not the way
forward you've got to get your head in
the game because the kind of mistakes
that you made tonight represents a chef
that doesn't seem to give a [ __ ] I do
give a [ __ ] I do I listen I drink too
much you know but why are you doing this
to
I don't know
I just don't know I'm like I'm lost and
lost his face
why I don't know life's just getting
tough for me man no I mean this business
is failing everybody wanted I got two
daughters going to college and I'm just
trying to like make it you know and it's
not working anymore you know
I don't know where to move from here
it's hard for me you know
this is my passion I only know how to
cook that's all I've ever done you know
since I was 19 years old the passion
when did that go I don't know after dad
passed away
yes
you know since my father died I'm
starting to give up I am I I could admit
it to you I'm like I feel defeated is
that why you're drinking more yeah
probably
you can't go down this Limelight you
cannot go down this line it's bigger
than the end I'm telling you
well I don't know what to do next I
really don't I'm confused
but you've got to get out of denial and
there's got to be a fire in your belly
that you've got to rekindle
that's all
okay I'll try my best okay see you in
the morning good night good night
this restaurant is definitely taking
entirely everything falls on my lap and
it's and it's wearing me out
it's a tough life
[Music]
after the death of his father Mike has
been in a downward spiral and so has his
restaurant he has clearly lost his way
and Chef Ramsay knows that in order for
this restaurant to have any chance of
surviving how are you morning I'm good
how are you he has to put Mike back on
course
quite nice getting out of the
restaurants yeah yeah he almost feels
like it's um
like a ticking time bomb in there and
I'm concerned I think really about that
and I had a chat with him last night and
he was for the first time being open and
honest
he admitted he lost control and sadly
that he was on the verge of giving up
and we can't give up
and then I noticed something upsetting
last night is the amount of drink
I feel like he's trying to drown his
size
yeah definitely I think he's very lost
right now everything fell on his
shoulders after after Nellie passed away
and it's so much more responsibility and
it's a lot to handle yeah I don't think
he got over losing his father I don't
think he's got over that hurdle I don't
think so no no I mean we were he was
back at work you know and there was no
time off it was he was just there I
think he's hurting I think deep down
inside I I don't see her happy no you
can tell that he's hurting
like always
[Music]
that's awful I mean he's got two kids in
college and like what does he have to
show for it like he's working so much
harder than he should be and like he's
suffering so much and I hate to see him
like that
your dad is driving himself into the
ground yeah
and I don't know how much longer you
know he can continue to do it
you know it's about time we actually
turned around and said hey Dad I want
you back I don't want you to listen I
don't want you to slow down
he should dance Yuri's Last Hope
and last night that was a cry for help I
think you can help them yeah of course
I'm here to help but I can't help unless
he's prepared to change himself
hello chefs morning Mike how are you hey
uh tough night last night right yeah
quite I came to see the girls because I
think the bottom line is my human a lot
to this family and there's no doubt in
how hard you're working but you're not a
machine you're not 25 Mike you're 55.
and the girls got something to say and I
want you to listen okay and I'll see you
back at the restaurant okay okay thank
you
thank you girls bye
so uh what do you want to tell me like
really difficult seeing you like
struggling this much and working so hard
you have to let go a little bit and
not work as hard as you are I understand
I understand I don't know how to let go
I don't trust anybody else but I think
that in order for you to be able to
function like this you need to let some
other people take out some
responsibilities I would love to take
take off and let them I know you I know
but you know trust trust them enough to
do it you know you have your guard off
all the time I do you know you don't
like trust anything whether we need a
nicer mic is that what you're saying no
we need a more open and like okay
so I'm willing to
give a shot a change here
people actually just talk to you it's
not going to be an overnight thing but
I'm willing to listen I've been wanting
to tell my dad do things for a long time
already
[Music]
and problem with the restaurant isn't
that we need a decoration change the
fact that my dad needs the change
after spending the morning at Mike's
home Chef Ramsay is anxious to get Mike
back in the kitchen show me the fridges
and reignite his passion with food well
here's the meat steaks go right up on
the grill
Jesus those trees no I didn't clean them
last night I got out of here they're a
little messy
I don't know that's chicken farm that's
cooked yeah that's cooked that's with
raw
we don't get these fridges changed at
night Sunday notes we do a deep cleaning
so it's Monday yesterday was Sunday
night yeah
are they all kept like this
hi you gotta cover this stuff seriously
what else you got going on here
look at this I'm getting nervous now 30
years in the business come on I'm
thinking holy [ __ ] what else is he gonna
find in here that is gonna embarrass me
oh you're kidding me what is that who's
responsible for this
I was looking forward to working with
the chefs on fixing the food show me The
Frigid that is until he made a series of
shocking discoveries oh you're kidding
me what is that who's responsible for
this
come on come on
seriously why is it in here
where's the walking right over here
you are kidding me what is that that's
the lobster bisque [ __ ]
eggplant
is that this is a calamari from last
night it was prepped yesterday
you can't leave fridges like this I do
know those things need to be changed I
try to do it after Michael and he won't
listen to me my food got served from
that fridge last night unbelievable
what's in here
[Music]
those are meatballs what were they made
they were made
last week how did you know it's a week
old no dates does that make any sense
come on this is basic
become sloppier and I need to start
making things right the French has been
ignored at the end of the evening and
then food's left in the oven oh come on
you're absolutely right it's a disgrace
I'm discovering that what am I supposed
to do now where do we start tell me
what time are the team in 2 30. get them
in earlier I want that whole [ __ ]
place clean you're better than this
[ __ ]
yo get a ride in as quickly as possible
Chef Ramsay wants everybody here now
so I believe it's time to turn this
place upside down some things are
falling through the cracks but cracks
can be filled everything can be fixed
every night from now on no more [ __ ]
around all right you can't do what I'm
doing I'm gonna have to change if I want
to change my restaurant
goodbye beer I'm ready this is where
we're going to start to fix this place
with a thorough cleaning by the staff
and what appears to be a change in
Attitude by Mike first of all the place
is looking cleaner Chef Ramsay can now
turn his attention to the area that
needs the most help the kitchen so I'm
going to do two steaks a rib eye on the
bone and a fillet I've been cooking
steaks for 32 years I know how I do it
which is the right way but maybe he can
teach me something in a nice one I'm
going to kill you kind of way
foreign
with that I'm gonna do a chive Mash just
great to see how his hands move like a
ballet with his fingers I was in awe
that's a real mashed potato
I touch a horseradish well spotted
it felt super inspired you like Chef
Ramsay I don't know how to put it into
words right now asparagus and fries for
the filet Touch of creme fraiche perfect
I'm used to cooking like one certain way
and this is a little different when you
spend a fortune on the ingredients I
want the customers to taste them I want
it to ooze the flavor of a rib eye
simply done let's have a little uh taste
yeah I'm feeling very very well I can
already feel the fire burning in my gut
which is something that has not happened
in a while uh weighty stuff get some
knife and Falls dig in everybody's good
oh my gosh it just melts in her mouth I
love the asparagus I'm coming over I'm
so excited to see my dad so happy it
seems like he really does want to change
things and make things better and I know
he can really do it can I order this for
dinner this is so good
now that Mike has finally seen the light
with how his Stakes can be improved I
don't want food to go out that we got
it's a private server Chef Ramsay is now
focused on the makeover of Mike and
Nelly and he begins with something that
has been driving him crazy since the day
he walked into the restaurant
I need some help okay I've come across
the most wretched carpet I've ever seen
and it is deplorable so Annie's
something durable something strong
something that can take a lot of
footfall okay yeah that's nice I like
that one as well with the blue can we
get this done tonight is that possible
absolutely with one major change in
motion Chef Ramsay's team is hard at
work trying to accomplish one of the
most difficult makeovers they have ever
faced
[Music]
Mike I've never seen you look so nervous
I'm speechless you're speechless okay
today I am proud
to unveil the new Mike and Ellis are you
ready yeah yeah let's do it okay
one
two
three
oh my God Mike and Nellie's Steakhouse
oh my God it's so nice look at that
wasn't that Mike and Nellie's steak and
seafood wow what this community's
lacking is a great Steakhouse yes
Steakhouse has been my dream my whole
life long
[Music]
right now I'm so overwhelmed with
emotion I don't even know how I'm
standing here my
let's go guys
everybody ready ready go straight into
the restaurant off you go jump in
oh my God oh my God
it is gorgeous
wow
[Music]
transformation welcome to the new Mike
and Ellis this is okay this is awesome
we walk in see the restaurant for the
first time we see Modern Art the new
chairs the new carpet I can't get a
smile off my face it's outstanding it's
awesome
this is okay look at this place wow gone
are those hideous arches we've opened
the restaurant up you have a very
elegant open space and it's stylish gong
is the old worn out decor and replaced
with a stunning contemporary rustic look
new carpets and that smell has gone I
want to take my shoes off
[Music]
my dream my whole life was to be a
steakhouse it's an absolute
transformation that's beyond my wildest
dreams Janine how are you feeling I
we're gonna be the Talk of the Town yeah
and we're gonna and we're gonna do you
proud trust me you can do your sales
prep
if Nelly was here right now he would be
so happy he really was and I could feel
him here now
foreign
addition to the updated look and new
identity
come in please Chef Ramsay has created
an elegant flavorful Modern menu
welcome to the new Mike and Ellie's menu
this menu is our foundation our new
start to Mike and Ellis simple delicious
and modern you can't see this look it's
incredible let's start off at the top of
the table we're here Maryland crab cakes
delicious simple serve with a Old Bay
mayonnaise yeah Angus sliders age white
cheddar shaved lettuce and a Special
Sauce the Hallmark of this restaurant
it's gonna be the steaks I love it start
off with the filet mignon eight ounce
beautifully grilled finish with that
wonderful delectable butter New York's
trip 12 ounce modern and beautiful and
stunning next to that we've got a
delicious braised short rib that served
with a red wine sauce and whipped chai
potatoes the side dishes look at that
mac and cheese oh my God how can you
have a steakhouse with no mac and cheese
it's top with some crispy breadcrumbs
delicious unbelievable right guys you
get some spoons knife and forks some
toys
Sam trust you to go straight for the
desserts they're fantastic oh my God the
full light I'm gonna get over there
oh my God I thought my food was good but
the new menu is just unbelievable
oh my God this is so good you are the
man Chef Ramsay you came in here and you
turned us completely around this is
definitely the start of something big I
see this restaurant going far
[Music]
as the doors open on relaunch night
hello welcome to the new Mike and
Nellie's welcome there's excitement in
the air and a buzz in the dining room
decor is awesome now as customers are
eager to try out the new Mike and Nelly
Steakhouse back in the kitchen here we
go guys yes Chef Ramsay wants the
workload divided with Mike doing less
and Dan doing more Daniel I'm trying to
get him to break away you are the future
so show it to me and show it to him yes
because Mike focus on the grill okay I'm
wanting Daniel running this and
coordinate the kitchen tonight I hope
Mike will back off a little and let me
come in and help him out I'm very
capable of taking over the most
important thing is that everything goes
out perfect I'm hoping that Dan can
handle the rush I've been trying to find
a chef for the last 15 years I can do
what I do this is nerve-wracking [ __ ]
here we go first ticket order in trim it
well one strip medium I want to hear an
echo a call back I got two strips eating
well thank you buddy so far Chef
Ramsay's plan is working Mike gets the
first Stakes on the grill wipe the plate
down please make it look pretty come on
Dan gets the kitchen in sink crab cakes
up in the window useful let's go and
customers are receiving their appetizers
[Music]
and the reviews are glowing next on
train short ribs strip mid-rare one rib
eye mid rareness french fry where are
those fries coming right now baby 25
seconds 25 seconds all right I'm feeling
great everybody is working together as a
team we're gonna be firing okay hold on
I have four fillets up here but only one
hour into service Mike is no longer
working in tandem with Dan order a
tomato a Caesar crab cake that's the one
I just called for that's going out and
instead of allowing Dan to organize Mike
is now
the kitchen stop take a step back and we
grew let's go next take you to strip
medium fillet medium all right let's
start putting these steaks out we've
just stopped listening to each other I'm
the main Cog in this restaurant I always
have been always will be yeah I was
doing this before you were going Mike
you can't slip into these old ways
you're killing me here man I don't know
what's gonna happen Blake's not
listening to what Chef Ramsay is saying
we've all forgotten what the [ __ ] we're
doing in here everything is falling
apart everything is going to [ __ ] like
just let me do this you know what slow
the [ __ ] down you're going ahead I have
no idea what you're talking about dude
your [ __ ] is over big time and right
now heading up it's only an hour it's a
relaunch at Mike at Nellie's we're going
to be firing
I have four fillets up here Micah
slipped back into his old ways and is
refusing to share the leadership of the
kitchen with Dan going ahead I have no
idea what you're talking about dude and
a successful relaunch is in Jeopardy I
need you running this I coordinate the
kitchen properly and I want you to be
behind him yes yes sir all right let's
pick up one strip medium cook it up a
ribeye shrimp chicken and ribeye yeah
I'm I'm losing you you're confirming to
me you're not lifting one little bit I
know it's hard but it's not [ __ ]
difficult it will be if you don't listen
get them working for you I need Daniel
now to start firing these orders right
okay come on you can do this this
restaurant is not all about me I need
help to run it and down to the man to do
it
drip
I got it Daniel the rare's going on
it'll be two minutes with Dan regaining
control of the tickets yeah tell me
again what's going on right now filet
medium Cod fillet medium in a Cod got it
the kitchen has found a proper rhythm
you're eating well on the right chef
Mike yes sir our steaks look fantastic I
got it baby my table loved all their
steaks thank you I got zero complaints
about the food tonight everything was
amazing steak's rested yes they are put
it out baby Dan was really into his job
tonight and really took a lot of
pressure off of me
like the way it looks in here the food
will be out in plenty of time and you'll
love it it was very rewarding walking
around out there I felt my father's
Spirit here watching over me and
everybody and it felt wonderful how you
doing Daddy I can't get the smile off my
face my dad completely turned it around
it's great to see I'm so happy Mike how
was the dining room I'm good but
everybody looks happy and smiling keep
it that way all right brother Ford is
clear Chef Ramsey showed my staff that
they need to support what I do everybody
did great I think this is going to be
the most successful place around here
hello
let me tell you something when I first
arrived your head was in the grill
stubborn wouldn't come out you've
transformed and worked with me thank you
in there right now is the spirit of
Nelly I agree and for me that is enough
to confirm that you can do it I believe
in you thank you sir
thank you so much for everything we
appreciate everything you did
more
thank you it's been a pleasure
yeah keep it going yes well done it's
our friends inspired me I was ready to
close this place up I thought we got
through it we persevered now I'm gonna
rock this place I'm gonna rock this town
come here my father Nelson would be
crying right now overwhelmed by Joy I
know he's watching
Patty thank you
you're proud of me good job thank you
sir yeah look after him will you will do
thank you for everything thank you so
much again get that spirit in there well
done
when I first arrived at Mike and Ellis
this had to be the most depressing
restaurant in America from the food to
The Deco even to the owner but tonight
with the help of a guardian angel named
Nelly a miracle happens because this
restaurant become the hottest Steakhouse
in the hole in New Jersey I just hope it
will continue along those lines
[Music]
that carpet I've never smelled anything
so disgusting in all my [ __ ] life I'm
sure there's bodies under there
in the weeks that followed business and
Mike and Nellie's boomed it's amazing
clearly the new menu is a big hit in
this New Jersey Town
look at this menu my God this is a
classic Steakhouse menu my customers
love it outstanding this is the whole
turnaround I've been waiting for Dan has
been outstanding in his new role in the
kitchen 15 seconds 15 seconds do we have
those strips made well right now baby
and Mike is embracing the change
allowing him to spend more time with his
diners thank you and now he's following
in the footsteps of his father I love
you too and there is nobody happier than
his two daughters Samantha and Lexie
[Music]